the State Department issued an urgent
warning overnight telling all Americans
in Iraq to leave the country immediately
in Lea's in Baghdad the death of Qasem
Soleimani in Baghdad ignited a new
chapter of regional tensions Iran's
supreme leader Ali Khamenei took to
Twitter vowing severe revenge this
morning iran backed Hezbollah in Lebanon
ordered its quote resistance fighters
around the world to avenge soleimani a
Rock's prime minister says the
assassinations are a massive breach of
sovereignty and the security agreement
with the United States now needs
reevaluation American allies in the
region like Israel are preparing for
possible retaliation and are on high
alert so are American forces with 9,000
in the region and 3,000 extra preparing
to deploy hours before the killings US
troops from the 82nd Airborne Division
arrived in Kuwait Soleimani
is a polarizing figure here in Iraq his
death exposes deep divisions on the
country streets impact dad's Tahrir
Square anti-government protesters
celebrated the news of his death
accusing Soleimani of being behind the
deaths of many demonstrators in recent
months the question now isn't whether
Iran will strike back but rather how and
to what severity and when it's over will
the killing of Soleimani have been worth
it for CBS this morning
Ian Lee in Baghdad Ian Lee for as Ian
thank you very much
you